Young prince Thutmose took a nap in the
shadow of the Sphinx's head which
seems to indicate that only the head was
sticking up out of the ground
the Sphinx appears to him right at the
zenith when the Sun is at its highest
point and basically the Sphinx says hey I am
drowning in sand here if you can dig me
out I will make you king of Egypt, so the
King awakes, he excavated the Sphinx and
became King. How do we know all this?
Because he then took a block of granite
brought it down to the Sphinx, carved
this story on it.
The Stela process involves first
doing restoration of the original
plaster cast; this was joining fragments,
correcting any earlier casting
errors and then creating a silicon mold
of that plaster cast; we could then pour
into the back of it casting resin,
I'm using a urethane resin and building
it up through multiple layers to create
depth of color that replicates a faux
stone. What we're working on right now is
mimicking pink granite which is what the
original Stela is made of but over time
parts of it have been worn away and
actually the cast we're working on right
now has more preserved of the Stela
than the existing actual Stela
the top part of the cast and the bottom
part of the cast are gonna stand about
eight feet tall and seven feet wide so
it's definitely pretty impressive.
This is a brand new form of casting for us so
it's been really fun to learn a new
process
we're hoping to bring the physical
object into the gallery, an augmented
reality aspect to have an educational
feature as well and this will be useful
for students, the visiting public, and try
to bring it all back